seine-saint-denis sage dans le groupe
l'est républicain vice-président du
sénat dont jean philippe bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin on va
commencer par cette actualité
sénatoriales la majorité assez naturel
de la droite et du centre qui va donc
déposer aujourd'hui une proposition de
loi constitutionnelle qui vise à
garantir la prééminence des lois de la
république l'objectif c'est d'armes et
la constitution contre le
communautarisme et notamment d'inscrire
le mot laïcité dans l'article 4 de la
constitution c'est celui qui concerne
les partis politiques
vous pensez que la constitution n'est
pas assez armé aujourd'hui face au
communautarisme
à l'évidence oui parce que on a pu
constater dans le passé un certain
nombre de dérives qui n'était pas rendue
impossible par nos textes et donc le
fait de réaffirmer un certain de
principes tels que la proposition de
philippe malfait me semble effectivement
une très bonne idée donc on aura une
sorte de chapeau qui va venir rappeler
les règles fortes et qui doivent
empêcher effectivement toute dérive
communautariste
cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle intervient alors que
les manuels macron a dit qu'il
s'exprimerait sur la question du
communautarisme dans les semaines à
venir avant les municipales
c'est une façon de la part de la droite
sénatoriale de mettre la pression sur le
chef de l'état écoutez ça fait deux ans
quasiment et peut-être même un peu plus
qu'on nous annonce un grand discours du
chef de l'état sur ces sujets là et ce
discours devient bab
beaucoup s'interrogent et se demande
pourquoi donc les parlementaires sont
pleinement dans le rôle en faisant des
propositions pour effectivement encadrer
les choses et au delà de ce discours qui
ne vient pas c'est vrai que beaucoup
s'interrogent sur la colonne vertébrale
des manuels macron sur ces sujets là il
apparaît parfois eu des propositions ou
des décisions qui n'étaient enfin qu'ils
pouvaient se mit doute donc on attend ce
discours avec avec beaucoup d'impatience
mais disent ils que doit dire la chef de
l'état d'écouter qu'il rappelle ce que
sont les valeurs de notre république et
qu'il réaffirme effectivement qu'il
n'est pas question d'aller peu ou prou
dans le sens de l'acceptation de
différenciation qui se ferait sur le bas
sur la base par exemple de conviction
religieuse ça ça n'est pas acceptable la
liberté de conscience c'est une chose
avec garantie dans notre démocratie mais
pour autant alors nos quinquas
effectivement selon elle cela ne doit
primer sur les lois de la république
pour vous aujourd'hui à la république
avait menacé par communautaire
écoutez il ya un certain nombre de
choses effectivement qu'on aurait pu
éviter quand on reparle parents pleurent
parler et ça ne date pas d'hier de ce
qu'avait accepté certaines municipalités
avec des horaires particuliers dans les
piscines
ça commence par cela et puis ça peut
aller beaucoup plus loin donc je pense
qu'il est en effet la présence est bien
évidemment c'est ce qu'avait accepté la
ville de lille si ma mémoire est bonne
on ne peut pas aller dans cette
direction là parce que est d'ailleurs la
pression est de plus en plus forte sur
le terrain et c'est pourquoi il faut
mieux encadrer les choses allaient autre
sujet c'est ce quoi que dans la majorité
cet émoi dans la classe politique suite
au rejet par la majorité présidentielle
d'une proposition de loi eu des qui
visait à rallonger le congé pour un
parent qui perdaient un enfant la
ministre muriel pénicaud a admis une
erreur collective de l'exécutif et de la
majorité elle s'engage à proposer un
texte plus ambitieux qu est ce que vous
avez pensé de ce vote de la part de la
majorité
écoutez c'est un un couac de plus
absolument incompréhensible l'air ce que
je ne comprends pas c'est que le groupe
u10 à l'assemblée nationale fait partie
de la majorité donc j'ai en général
lorsqu'un groupe de la majorité des
pauses une ppl sens général avec
l'accord du gouvernement alors mais
justement là ça n'était pas le cas alors
peut-être que le groupe eut dit espérer
qu'en séance les députés de la majorité
se laisserait convaincre ça n'a pas été
le cas tout cela donne un sentiment d'un
préparation avec une ministre qui fait
marche arrière devant effectivement la
réaction tout à fait justifiée de
l'opinion enfin je suis passé un
sentiment d'amateurisme
c'est assez étonnant rapidement de cette
proposition nous allons le faire nous
allons fermer d'ailleurs la mitterie
sera même dit qu' il allait faire
machine arrière et alors je ne sais pas
sous quelle forme et comment mais
revenir sur ce refus que personne ne
comprend nous même déposé effectivement
une ppl c'est la possibilité maintenant
je pense qu il mais la question est de
savoir ce qui va se passer dans les
jours à venir est ce que faire le
gouvernement allait l'autre sujet c'est
cette réforme des retraites
début aujourd'hui de l'examen à
l'assemblée nationale un commission
spéciale 22 mille amendements déposés
dont dix neuf mille rien que pour la
france insoumise qui assume une
stratégie d'obstruction parlementaire
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de cette
stratégie la stratégie du concept
absurde
les parlementaires aussi bien
l'assemblée que le sénat les
parlementaires se plaignent de ne pas
avoir assez de temps pour examiner ce
texte
alors quand en plus effectivement en
dépose 19 mille amendements pour
empêcher la discussion de fond c'est
effectivement allé dans le sens que l'on
conteste ça me semble absolument
ridicule je pense que l'assemblée
nationale a mieux à faire que cela
voilà donc on sait la stratégie de
radicalisation de la france insoumise on
la voit sur le terrain on la voit dans
les propos de jean-luc mélenchon et ça
se traduit par 19 mille amendements à
l'assemblée nationale ça n'est pas
raisonnable en tous les cas ça n'est pas
un gage de bonne qualité du travail
parlementaire
comment examiner 22 mille amendements au
total en commission lorsque déjà le
temps est extrêmement course impossible
donc franchement ça va dans le mauvais
sens
je pense que le parlement doit
réaffirmer ses droits et exiger
effectivement des délais raisonnables
pour examiner les textes mais alors si
effectivement on dépose autant
d'amendements c'est l'exact opposé que
le long que l'on provoque donc senna ça
n'a pas de sens par une partie des
parlementaires dont la droite
sénatoriale un contexte le calendrier de
cette réforme des retraites gérard
larcher dit dans le journal du dimanche
qu'il continuera à demander la fin de la
procédure accélérée qui prévoit une
seule lecture par chambre demande va
coûter on verra bien vous savez les
choses peuvent encore évoluer je pense
que dans la majorité et le président de
la république au premier chef doit
vraiment s'apercevoir que ça se passe
mal parce que c'est un conflit qui dure
avec une radicalisation sur le terrain
avec des actes de plus en plus violents
du côté de certains on en était même à
bloquer en région ile de france qui
pourrait poser un problème effectivement
les centres de tri des ordures ménagères
il ya les coupures de courant
intempestives et puis surtout l'opinion
publique n'est pas convaincu par
l'utilité de cette réforme et non
comprend même pas les grands principes
que même pas parler vous du chiffrage
qui est
tous les cas on n'a aucune visibilité là
dessus pour le moment mais je pense que
président de la république serait bien
inspiré effectivement de se donner du
temps quelle est l'urgence à vouloir
absolument légiférer d'ici l'été ça n'a
pas de sens il n'y a pas d'urgence
absolue au moins à ce niveau là quoi ça
veut dire quoi qu'il faut attendre il
faut carrément décalé l'examen au
parlement le faire en septembre pour
vous l'examen on pourrait avoir de
lecteurs ce qui effectivement nous
amènerait probablement à l'automne mais
je pense que franchement ça serait de
bon sens et j'espère que le président de
la république et le premier ministre en
conviendront finalement vous dites le
que l'opinion publique ne comprend pas
les grands principes de cette réforme
pourtant ces grands principes la droite
sénatoriale la droite tout court
d'ailleurs les défendent est-ce que
c'est pas compliqué pas non plus qu'il
n'a jamais défendu une retraite par
points qui viendraient ben écoutez cette
idée de régime universel a contraint de
réforme des retraites à temps vous vos
on a toujours dit qu'il faudrait
repousser l'âge de départ je pense que
de toutes les manières on va le faire
mais passer à un système par points soit
disant universelle jamais nous n'avons
proposé une mesure pareille et
d'ailleurs au fil du temps s'aperçoit
que le caractère universel de cette
réforme il n'existera parme est en train
d'en exclure les catégories les unes
après les autres
est ce que vous vous reposez à savoir
reporter l'âge de départ à 65 ans est
pas encore plus difficile à faire face
mais qu'est ce que vous croyez qu'il va
se passer avec la nouvelle réforme
de toute façon d'ailleurs on nous avait
dit l'âge pivot où l'âge des équilibres
je sais plus comment il faut l'appeler
ça serait de toute façon 64 ans dont
tout le monde sait que pour équilibrer
un système quel qu'il soit on devra
travailler plus longtemps
le drame dans cette affaire c'est que le
président de la république a dit le
contraire en 2017 et que maintenant ils
ne savent plus comment faire donc qui
sont à la fois sur une réforme
paramétrique est systémique et la partie
systémique plus personne n'y comprend
rien et le gouvernement s'est aperçu
mais bien trop tard
faute d'avoir sérieusement creuser le
sujet que il ya c'est pas possible de
mettre en place un régime universel où
tout le monde sera traité de la même
manière
donc voilà on est dans une impasse a
vraiment il faut renoncer à ces régimes
par points être se concentrer sur la
mesure d'âge pour équilibrer je pense
qu'on aurait mieux fait effectivement de
ne pas se lancer dans cette affaire de
régime universel par points
le
on répète il est juste il est juste il
est juste le problème c'est qu'ils ne
convainc personne
pour la bonne et simple raison que c'est
indémontrable à l'essai dans ce contexte
social compliqué hein que le sénat va
examiner demain la proposition doit pour
un service minimum dans les transports
pendant la grève c'est un texte déposé
par bruno retailleau le président du
groupe l'est républicain au sénat on va
en parler avec elle exposa jamais
bonjour yann bonjour philippe dallier
bonjour et alex le sénat qui examine
donc demain la proposition de bruno
retailleau sur le service minimum dans
les transports
et oui on va faire un petit retour en
arrière on va retourner fin novembre
2019 nous sommes à quelques jours du
début de la grève contre la réforme des
retraites et bruno retailleau soit
choisi ce moment pour annoncer dans le
journal du dimanche qu'il va déposer une
proposition de loi pour assurer un
service minimum dans les transports en
grève avec deux mesures principales
l'objectif d'un tiers du trafic aux
heures de pointe trafic assuré
et puis la possibilité pour les
entreprises de réquisitionner le
personnel gréviste écouter sur ce point
bruno retailleau
il ya des fonctionnaires en france qui
sont interdits de droit de grève y en a
d'autres qui peuvent être réquisitionnés
tout comme d'ailleurs dans d'autres
grandes démocraties non il ya d'un côté
un une valeur constitutionnelle c'est à
dire le droit de grève mais il ya de
l'autre une autre valeur
constitutionnelle qui est le principe de
continuité des services publics
le droit de grève c'est aussi un droit
qui comprend un certain nombre de
limites alors à l'époque bruno
retailleau a très bien choisi son
calendrier puisqu'il a promis de déposer
son texte d'ici au 5 décembre c'est à
dire le jour de la première grève contre
la réforme des retraites
et ce coup médiatique il n'a pas
vraiment plu au premier ministre à
l'époque edouard philippe
ecoutez-le nous le savons tous les
grandes propositions qui interviennent
la veille d'un mouvement grève sont
souvent des façons d'attirer l'attention
du public sur un sujet et peut être un
peu moins une façon de régler
durablement une question juridique
délicate
alors depuis le texte est arrivé au
sénat et avant d'être débattu demain
dans l'hémicycle il a d'abord été
examiné par la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat qui a apporté quelques
modifications au texte
regardez on ne parle plus et bien d'un
tiers du trafic aux heures de pointe qui
serait assuré de manière garantie mais
il s'agit de répondre aux besoins de la
population dans un endroit donné
donc ça peut être un tiers du trafic ça
peut être également 50% du trafic assuré
en tout cas c'est à l'autorité
organisatrice des transports dans la
région concernée de définir ce service
minimum est par exemple en ile de france
ce seront les élus régionaux et
départementaux qui vont décider de ce
service minimum
et puis la commission sénatoriale
prévoit le remboursement des usagers
pénalisés en remboursement automatique
dans les sept jours qui concernerait les
usagers qui paient par voie
dématérialisée alors en tout cas dans le
débat qui arrive demain dans l'hémicycle
et bien la gauche du sénat sera vent
debout contre ce texte
écoutez le patron des sénateurs
socialistes patrick kanner si vous
faites grêve ex n'a aucune conséquence
sur votre environnement
c'est à dire que si vous ne pouvez pas
faire passer un message pour dire mais
nous sommes en grève
nous savons que nous apportons des
perturbations dans votre vie quotidienne
mais c'est pour qu'on puisse être
écoutés voilà c'est plat il faut dire
tout de suite on supprime le droit de
grève dans notre constitution et le
droit de grève il fera l'objet d'un
débat très tendue demain entre la gauche
et la droite du sénat entre gauche et
droite
écoutez me semble pas que nous
proposions l'interdiction du droit de
grève
les propos de patrick kanner sont quand
même assez étonnant on est dans une
période
et elle dure elle dure cette période et
elle a été très difficile
particulièrement en région ile de france
où les gens qui ont besoin d'utiliser
tous les jours les transports en commun
ont vécu une véritable galère donc
effectif
écoutez franchement on est sur du
service public on peut pas toujours
vouloir les avantages sans les
inconvénients quand on est fonctionnaire
ou quand on exerce effectivement une
mission de service public
et bien il y a effectivement des
obligations donc si jamais on adopte ce
texte c'est qu'effectivement soit mis en
place un service minimum à un tiers ou à
50%
qu'on ne nous dise pas que c'est
l'interdiction du droit de grève c'est
ridicule
je pense que dans une démocratie comme
la nôtre on peut tout à fait encadrer
les choses et c'est ce que propose cette
ppl
ça va faire perdre les effets d'une
grève finalement et du coup est ce que
le message c'est en région ile de france
à partir du moment où vous avez 50 % de
grévistes ou même 70 % de grévistes vous
imaginez que personne ne s'en aperçoit
franchement non donc c'est une même la
moitié c'est une dégradation tellement
importante du niveau de service public
que tout le monde aura bien compris que
certains sont en grève
donc les propos de patrick camair sont
quand même assez assez malvenu vous qui
êtes élus de la région ile de france
dans cette proposition non lavés avec
alex ce sont les élus de la région et de
département qui vont décider du service
minimum vous trouvez que c'est une bonne
chose mais c'est l'autorité
organisatrice des transports donc
effectivement je pense que c'est une
possibilité intéressante
allez on va se rendre dans une rédaction
locale on va continuer à parler
transport mais d'un autre sujet vous
allez voir on va aller à brive la
gaillarde à retrouver série greggy
bonjean sert il de la vie corrézienne et
l'actualité dans votre département et
bien ce sont les 90 km heure depuis
samedi fini les 80 km/heure le
département il repassait en 90
effectivement depuis samedi les
corréziens on vous l'a de nouveau à 90
km heure c'était une promesse en tout
cas l'engagement fort du président du
conseil départemental pascal costes qui
dès janvier 4
juste s'étaient élevées contre décision
de 80 kilomètres heure
il a d'ailleurs proposé des jurys 2018
de la courage devienne un département
expérimental pour les 90 km heure alors
du coup c'est comment ça s'est passé sur
place a été c'est une demande des
habitants ça a été bien perçu ça a été
facile pour le président du conseil
départemental de revenir sur ces 80 km h
si je ne sais pas mais en tout cas il ya
eu unanimité et des conseillers
départementaux a priori qui ont pris
position pour ce retour 90 km heure un
gros travail a été mis en place par les
services du département qui en
concertation avec les acteurs locaux de
la sécurité routière ont étudié un petit
peu et des possibilités
il ya une grosse études d'accidentologie
qui a été menée sur le département qui a
conduit donc à ce que le département
repasse devant 80 km heure avec l'aval
de la commission départementale de
sécurité routière
on va parler de l'autre actualité un qui
vous concerne série de greg ce sont les
municipales comme dans tous les
départements comment ça se passe la
campagne des municipales en corrèze pour
l'instant c'est le grand petit peu calme
il me semble il et les choses se mettent
en place
57% des maires du département
le choix de repartir c'est plutôt plus
qu'on ne pouvait penser les mères sont
souvent par partie faute de faute de
candidats dont canal écoute commune
notamment où certains électrons des
difficultés à constituer des listes en
amont peut-être sur les grandes villes
de votre département en point sur la
campagne dans ces grandes villes lacombe
à l'aller vient juste de démarrer les
travaux
harvey yves acculé à ussel les choses
sont plutôt calme pour l'instant abri le
maire sortant les républicains reçu le
soutien de cette partie en fait de cette
secte personnalité cette personnalité du
la vivent ça doit venir ça se présente
plutôt bien pour lui à priori même si
une élection n'est jamais n'est jamais
garanti à tulle bernard combes que adoré
aussi lui avoir aussi pardon avoir un
chemin relativement simple même si sur
une candidature s'est présenté comme le
radical a eu cent us à 100 la peau plus
compliqué dans la mesure où le maire
sortant tous sauf rate redire se
retrouvent en lice face à ça enfin notre
rosneft on est accro mais ranger
adjointe françoise béziat et bien merci
beaucoup pour ce point c'est les y est
on va voir à la une de la vie
corrézienne c'est un hebdo une retour à
90 km/heure c'est pour demain l'hebdo
est donc sorti vendredi c'est donc fait
la corrèze est passé aux 90 km/heure
merci d'avoir été avec nous cyril on va
continuer à parler des municipales fini
de la lime et dans votre département de
la seine saint denis avec alex poussard
qui revient et alex on commence avec le
parisien et oui on va d'abord parler du
renseignement français qui déménage en
seine-saint-denis plus précisément dans
la commune de saint-ouen puisque en 2026
les 5500 fonctionnaires de la dgs et la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure et bien vont déménager dans
les anciens locaux du journal le
parisien également dans l'entreprise
voisine de spiritueux bacardi alors ses
locaux vont être complètement rasée pour
construire en 2026 et bien la nouvelle
cité du renseignement avec un coût de
l'opération 2 500 millions d'euros autre
sujet dans actu et seine saint denis et
oui cette fois ci on parle des violences
faites aux mères puisque la maire de
bondy a été insulté et menacé un mur a
été découvert samedi rempli de tags
d'insultés de menaces à l'encontre de la
maire socialiste de bon
dit sylvie thomassin qui se représente
aux élections municipales les violences
faites aux maires et bien on en a
beaucoup parlé dans cette émission et
c'est malheureusement encore aujourd'hui
un triste exemple
en tout cas la mère de mon dit a dit
qu'elle ne se laisserait pas
impressionner et qu'elle allait porter
plainte
maman philippe dallier sur ces violences
a envers les élus de plus en plus
nombreuses pour rester absolument
lamentable et 7 le signe également que
notre démocratie ne va pas bien voilà
certains sont dans une forme de
radicalisation et s'en prennent
maintenant physiquement voilà c'est pas
physiquement mais enfin ce qu'on a vu
sur les murs là c'est quand même assez
assez incroyable et puis il ya même
parfois des violences contre les
permanences électorales des
parlementaires et des violences
physiques voilà on connaissait pas ça il
ya une quinzaine ou une vingtaine
d'années c'est vraiment le signe que
notre démocratie ne va pas bien mais là
2,6 il faut être intransigeant et ne pas
laisser les choses dérivés elle est la
faute à keita via bertrand dans le jdd
disait qu emmanuel macron loin de
rassembler les français les a divisés
écoutez je veux pas faire de lien entre
ce que je viens de dire là sur ce qu'on
a vu à l'écran et le président de la
république maintenant on voit bien qu'on
est dans une période où les français
sont un peu déboussolés un peu paumé
voilà et certains en viennent à des
extrémités ont du mal à accepter les
règles de la démocratie parce que l'
élection qu'elle soit locale ou
présidentielle c'est quand même ça le
fondement de notre démocratie il
certains considèrent maintenant que
voilà les élections ça ne sert à rien et
on peut même s'en prendre aux élus voilà
tout ça ce sont de très beaux lots
signaux allait justement on va parler
d'élections à part les municipales en
salles en mai dans le parisien
et oui avec et bien le plan de bataille
de la droite aux élections municipales
dans le département de seine-saint-denis
un sujet qui vous concerne philippe
dallier puisque vous diriger la
fédération départementale du parti et
les républicains en seine-saint-denis et
si on en croit et bien l'article du
parisien votre objectif c'est de
consolider vos positions obtenues en
puisqu'en 2014 il faudra il faut le
rappeler la droite et le centre avaient
fait tomber quelques bastions
communistes dans ce département
notamment la commune de bobigny du
blanc-mesnil également de saint-ouen et
l'objectif serait donc est bien de
conserver la quarantaine de communes qui
est dirigée actuellement par la droite
et le centre
alors que dans ce département la
république en marche et le rassemblement
national sont très mal implanté merci
beaucoup à la xv est optimiste
la seine-saint-denis d'abord les 40
communes en seine-saint-denis nous en
dit région la moitié ce qui est
effectivement un store historiquement
haut pour 2014 mais notre objectif il
est temps en deux phases et le parisien
n'a parlé que de la première bien
évidemment on veut essayer de consolider
toutes les municipalités que nous avons
gagné en 2014 mais il ya aussi des
communes dans lesquelles nous avons de
bonnes chances de l'emporter on parlait
de bondy on a un candidat qui est à la
manoeuvre qui à mon avis a la
possibilité de l'emporter
et ça sera le cas dans d'autres communes
dans ce département notamment quand la
gauche est très divisée ou qu'elle est
absolument usées donc il ya pantin il ya
un certain nombre de communes montreuil
il va être intéressant de regarder ce
qui va se passer
[Musique]
le premier objectif c'est
d'effectivement de conserver ce qu'on
avait acquis en 2014 et il ya des
possibilités de conquête que largement
au delà de la 100e lien c'est la droite
qui était sorti vainqueur des élections
municipales en 2014 est ce que là aussi
vous pensez que vous allez pouvoir
regarder vos élus locaux je pense que
oui et je pense d'ailleurs que l' on le
voit d'ailleurs à l'attitude de la
république en marche qui était parti
triomphante il ya un an sur les
municipales et qui aujourd'hui fait
plutôt profil bas jusqu'à là jusqu'à la
circulaire castaner pour essayer de de
casser le thermomètre au moment du soir
du premier et du second temps donc moi
sur les républicains
oui mais écoutez alors chez les
républicains il ya ceux qui auront pris
le risque de de s'allier plus ou moins
avec la république en marche et je pense
que cela doivent commencer à le
regretter et puis ceux qui ne l'ont pas
fait je pense à tout ce qu'ils ont fait
et ceux qui ne l'ont pas fait donc
écouter parce que sur le terrain j'aime
autant vous dire et campagnes
électorales servent aussi à cela on sent
bien d'ailleurs moi je crains qu'il y
ait l'abstention est relativement forte
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point certes ce sont des élections
locales mais on sent aussi qu'il va y
avoir une partie des électeurs qui vont
vouloir envoyer un message et le message
à mon avis il ne sera pas favorable au
gouvernement
donc ce qui fait d'ailleurs sur le
terrain beaucoup d'électeurs parce que
vous savez on n'utilise pas les
étiquettes politiques en ce moment moi
je pense que ça n'est pas forcément une
l'idée de ne pas le faire il ya beaucoup
de gens qui nous demandent mais vous
êtes petit finalement 1 et quand on dit
on et les républicains ça passe quand on
dit les gens nous disent parfois vous
n'êtes pas avec la république en marche
non mais pas un quart de plus qu'en mars
nous on est pour la clarté
voilà d'autres ont fait d'autres choix
je suis pas certain que ça leur soit
très profitable à l'arrivée allez on
parlait justement de cette circulaire
castaner le conseil d'état qui l'a
suspendu cette circulaire l'us thann a à
la fois sur le nuance âge
christophe castaner qui voulait que les
préfets ne met pas de nuances politiques
pour les habitent les que les est
candidat donc les communes de moins de
9000 habitants et aussi sur la question
de cette fameuse étiquette divers
sentent qui vous concerne notamment
républicain qui voulait que les mères
ayant reçu un soutien de la république
en marche les petits crédits vers sens
mais n'ont pas dans leur famille
d'origine
est ce que c'est une victoire pour vous
cette décision du conseil d'état
tous les cas sale temps pour le
gouvernement
vis-à-vis du conseil d'état c'est la
première fois on a vu sur l'avis du
conseil d'état sur la réforme des
retraites ça a été d'une extrême
sévérité et la la circulaire 2010
l'intérieur a été retoquée et à juste
titre on voit bien que le gouvernement
va essayer de masquer le piètre résultat
de la république en marche et vous
donner un très bon exemple c'est à dire
qu'un mer et l'air encartés sheller qui
aurait reçu le soutien de la république
en marche aura été classé centre-droit
et monsieur k sa mère aurait pu venir le
soir du premier tour en disant regardez
comme c'est merveilleux toutes les
listes de centre-droit el rem pourquoi
pas et le résultat qu'elles ont obtenus
franchement un peu de clarté ne nuit pas
et ça montre bien la fébrilité du
gouvernement
al'approche de ces élections le
gouvernement qui s'engage dans ces
élections notamment le premier ministre
edward filet parce que vous trouve que
c'est une bonne chose qu'elle aille au
combat électoral
c'est courageux de sa part dans le
contexte je comprends tout à fait qu'ils
puissent être attaché à et ville du
havre maintenant pour les pour ceux qui
vont s'exprimer pour les électeurs c'est
un peu compliqué puisqu'il vient il est
en tête de liste mais il dit tout de
suite je ne serai pas le maire puisque
effectivement s'il reste premier
ministre il ne pourra pas être maire du
havre en même temps voilà donc c'est
assez courageux politiquement de sa part
mais c'était assez difficilement
explicable sur le terrain un dernier mot
sur ces élections puisque vous êtes un
des spécialistes du logement on préfère
agir sur cette proposition de benjamin
griveaux candidats à la république en
marche à la mairie de paris benjamin
griveaux qui parmi ses propositions dit
que la mairie donnera son 1000 euros
d'apport aux parisiens selon évidemment
un critère de revenus sains pour un
achat en résidence principale qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette proposition
je pense qu'à paris la campagne
électorale est en train de tourner à la
foire aux conneries
voilà il fallait que ça s'arrête quoi
parce que après le déplacement de la
gare de l'est en dons
d'ailleurs en seine saint denis on sait
pas très bien où là monsieur griveaux
propose de dépenser deux milliards
d'euros la ville de paris sg endetté à
hauteur de 6 milliards là il veut en
rajouter 2 milliards et il va donner
cent mille euros et il nous explique est
d'ailleurs première chose à dire c'est
que cette mesure va être inflationnistes
comme toutes les mesures en matière de
logements qui vise effectivement à
apporter des avantages à ce qu'ils vont
faire l'acquisition d'un bien lié à un
caractère inflationniste donc ça a
augmenté le prix ça va faire mal pris et
puis en plus on nous explique que au
moment de la revente on se repérer sur
la plus value mais si jamais le marché
se retourne alors c'est une perte pour
la ville on redemande à celui qui a
acheté de rembourser enfin tout ça n'a
aucun sens
on a l'impression que certains candidats
pour exister ont besoin de d'avancer des
propositions qui sont complètement
délirante et pour vous c'est irréel
c'est absolument chez délieront commerci